à didier billion directeur adjoint de
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques est avec nous lidié
billon bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors israël et les émirats arabes unis
on le disait ont annoncé avoir conclu un
accord de paix qualifiée d'historique
par donald trump notamment mais il ya
déjà eu un des rapprochements
précédemment entre ces deux états n'est
ce pas oui en fait fait lé point
d'aboutissement d'un très long processus
parce que nous savons que depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années
monsieur 30 et bien sûr mais la ligne
est amené au cherchait à tout prix a
essayé de de se rapprocher des états
arabes du golfe notamment des émirats
arabes unis parce que ahmed ben zayed a
la réputation d'être un stratège et
déraisonné sur le moyen terme ce qui est
le cas dans la région
donc c'était clairement une volonté de
rapprochement
on se souvient aussi que les émirats
arabes unis avaient eu un rôle assez
important dans la promotion du fameux
plantes rome qui a été annoncé
publiquement au mois dé janvier dernier
donc l'établissement de ces relations
diplomatiques n'est pas un petit
événement il faut le prendre en tant que
tel je ne suis pas certain que ce soit
historique comme monsieur 30 le dis très
rapidement mais en tout cas c'est un
événement d'art du grande importance
politique mais pour autant soldats ne
règle rien sur le fond c'est à dire que
on peut constater une nouvelle fois que
les principaux concernés de came ans sur
la question palestinienne à savoir les
dirigeants palestiniens n'ont
visiblement pas été du tout concertée
donc en réalité cet accord scelle un
processus qui était déjà alors comme je
lé brièvement rappelé mais ce
rapprochement ne permet en outre pas de
régler sur le fond la question
palestinienne la création d'un état
palestinien viable et la cessation
définitive de tout processus d'annexion
puisque je rappelle
dans cet accord est dans cet
établissement de relations diplomatiques
monsieur b namine et yahoo a promis
qu'il le suspende est la panique il
arrêtait définitivement mais qu'il chute
en mer d'accord on va y revenir
justement didier billion mais alors s'il
n'ya pas de changement sur le fond comme
vous venez de nous le dire pour autant
qu'elle changement cet accord peut-il
apporter pour les deux pays et pour le
moyen-orient alors c'est l'expression je
pense de modification de deux rapports
de force géopolitique ça fait très
important parce que selon personne ne
parle enfin la nouvelle est tombée il ya
très tout récemment donc nous n'avons
pas encore eu le temps de réfléchir
totalement conséquences que cela peut
avoir
et moi j'aimerais me dire deux mots sur
l'iran parce qu'on sait très bien que 1
une des obsessions d'administration au
trône
c'est d'isoler de continuer la pression
sur téhéran et d'isoler toujours plus
n'est l'iran or il est évident qu'un
rapprochement codifiée par
l'établissement de relations
diplomatiques entre deux états l'état
d'israël d'une part et un état arabe
d'autre part les émirats arabes unis est
un pas en avant dans cette volonté
d'établir un pur de cordon de sécurité
de plus en plus stricte au tour de
l'iran ça fait très important
et en ce sens c'est établissement de
relations diplomatiques prochaine à la
modification à la communication de la
modification des rapports de force au
géo politique et à la réorganisation des
alliances géopolitique régionale cela
est très important alors à l'un des
principaux éléments de l'accord était
censé être le renoncement d'israël à
l'annexion de territoires palestiniens
selon les émirats mais cela vient d'être
contredit par benyamin nétanyahou il
parle d'une injection repoussé on disait
et à laquelle israël ne renonce pas
alors comment les émirats arabes unis
peuvent-ils dans ces conditions vendre
cette normalisation avec l'état hébreu
aux autres pays arabes et au monde
musulman finalement ça fait la bonne
question qui pour se poser parce que un
des enjeux de ce de l'établissement des
relations diplomatiques était de
voir si les émirats arabes unis était
capable d'entraîner à leur suite
d'autres états arabes et on pense bien
évidemment notamment à l'arabie saoudite
or nous savons par exemple parce que
l'arabie saoudite est un pays central
dans la région nous savons que 6 mb/s
ahmed bin salman le jeune prince
héritier serait très favorable à
l'établissement de relations
diplomatiques avec israël
l'ast il considère pour sa part que la
question palestinienne doit passer pour
pertes et profits aux yeux de l'histoire
mais le problème c'est que son père qui
est toujours le roi régnant actuellement
en arabie sony n'est pas du tout sur la
même longueur d'onde et que les
saoudiens le roi saoudien veut des
garanties fermes quant à l'acceptation
définitive du processus d'annexion
on peut craindre d'ailleurs que de ce
point de vue les émirats arabes unis et
jouets ou est accepté de jouer h de
tubes c'est à dire que vous avez raison
signé contre ce que déclarent les
dirigeants émirati est ce que précise
monsieur netanyahu il ya quand même pour
le moins une différence est ce que ce
sera l'arrêt ou la suspension simplement
du processus d'annexion
la différence est grande et c'est bien
sur ce point que totti ne sera pas réglé
je doute que les émirats arabes unis
puissent entraîner derrière eux d'autres
vétérans
je pense que les autres et arabes une
bonne partie d'entre eux voudront des
garanties beaucoup plus importante
donc tout cela est assez assez compliqué
en tout cas s'il faut bien souligner est
que cet accord vient à point nommé et
constituer un joli cadeau à monsieur
tron dont on sait qu'il est quand même
dans une situation compliquée quand à sa
réélection au mois de novembre prochain
et qu'il va pouvoir se parer d'un
véritable succès diplomatique en tout
cas de son point de vue en tout ça pour
conclure
des billons nous en parlions tout à
leurs côtés palestiniens notamment le
hamas on ne veut pas entendre parler de
ce plan oui évidemment mais le hamas de
ce point de vue a plutôt raison c'est à
dire que considérant que les
palestiniens n'ont même pas été convié
aux discussions de la même façon
rappelez vous qu'au mois de janvier
dernier quand monsieur trump avait
proclamé publiquement son fameux plan
incluant d'ailleurs là la possibilité
pour les israéliens de procéder à
l'annexion de de nombreuses colonies à
partir du 1er juillet ce qui n'a pas été
fait ce qui montre que c'est très
compliqué en tout cas ce qui est clair
est que dans chaque grand rendez-vous
qui concerne les enjeux politiciens et
bien les premiers concernés ne sont même
pas convoqué en ce sens ça ne pourra pas
aboutir tant que les palestiniens ni la
direction palestinienne ne sera pas
réintégré de plein droit dans un
processus souhaitable de négociations
politiques et diplomatiques alors je
crains que cela ne règle rien sur le
front merci beaucoup didier billion pour
cet éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
directeur adjoint de l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques iris